flugzeuge vergiften und heimlich durch
wollten ähnliche chemtrails reptilien
aliens regieren die welt wir leben auf
der innenseite einer hohlen erdkugel
im internet findet anscheinend jede
theorie ihre anhänger egal wie weit
hergeholt sie auch klingen mag der
psychologe sebastian bartoschek
beschäftigt sich mit diesen digitalen
phänomen das netz ist ein guter
nährboden für die verbreitung
verschwörungstheorien weil ich gezielt
sachen suchen kann die zu meiner
weltsicht passen
und weil ich völlig ungefiltert auch
informationen einstellen kann das heißt
wo man früher mühevoll leute suchen
musste die ähnliche seltsame gedanken
haben finde ich das sofort heutzutage im
internet ein aktuelles beispiel der
durchgestrichene barcode auf den
flaschen der lammsbräu brauerei ein
kunde fragt im netz nach dem grund dafür
antwort des bio bierbrauers manche
menschen glauben dass barcodes
schädliche energien bündeln wir stehen
der theorie neutral gegenüber ist das
kundenservice ein marketing gag oder
spinnerei im netz wird das kontrovers
diskutiert diana paul kennt diese
diskussion
sie arbeitet für sonnentor ein
unternehmen das biologische gewürze und
tees er stellt auch diese firma hat ihre
barcode durch streichen lassen und damit
angeblich entschärft gegner hatten ihr
vorgeworfen verschwörungstheorien zu
unterstützen
daraufhin verzichtete sonnentor auf den
strich dass kamen über facebook das
wurde über blogs publiziert und da ging
dann eine regelrechte welle los und da
haben wir uns dann einfach noch mal auch
intensiver mit dem thema auseinander
gesetzt und gesagt okay wenn das gerade
unsere kunden so polarisiert dann
schauen wir uns das noch mal genauer an
sebastian bartoschek rät unternehmen
kundenwünsche genau zu prüfen
denn verschwörungstheoretiker nutzen
jede möglichkeit um ihr weltbild zu
bestätigen
wenn jetzt angesehene firmen in
irgendeiner form verschwörungstheorien
gedanken entgegenkommen sei es durch das
durchstreichen von barcodes oder dadurch
dass sie sagen gewisse elemente seien
nicht mehr in ihrem gespräch dann kriegt
das auf einmal eine legitimierung und
somit wird aus einem marketing gag
letztlich auf einmal einen ein quasi
wahrheit' beleg doch im netz tummeln
sich nicht nur verschwörungs anhänger
viele nehmen die theorien mit humor
einer von ihnen ist der journalist raik
anders er beschäftigt sich auf seinem
youtube kanal mit verschwörungen aller
art und klärt auf
seine videos erzählen mehrere
hunderttausend klicks das auf den ersten
blick selbst verschwörerisch wirken ist
gewollt
ich habe dann immer solche titel die
halt immer so wirken als wäre ich jetzt
komplett der anhänger der
verschwörungstheorien und damit versuche
ich die leute so ein bisschen aus ihrer
filter bubble rauszuziehen dass sie sich
vielleicht auf das video einlassen und
die naive hoffnung meinerseits ist ein
bisschen wenn sie halt erstmal auf das
video kommen durch den titel und dann
vielleicht sehen dass der inhalt
vielleicht immer neue informationen
geben können dass sie vielleicht ihre
eigene haltung noch mal überdenken oder
hinterfragen das sind chemtrails giftige
chemikalien die von flugzeugen in den
himmel gesprüht werden
sie sollen zum beispiel
lungenentzündungen asthma und alzheimer
auslösen
alles im auftrag einer welt
die menschen vergiftet so nicht
sportfreunde der youtuber hat eine klare
haltung
ich meine man will ja wissenschaftlich
immer nicht ausschließen das heißt in
dem moment wo jetzt wirklich eine große
wissenschaftliche untersuchung kommt die
dann festlegt dass die barcodes und
allen krebs besorgen oder was auch immer
dann werde auch ich jeden barcoo
durchreichen ich meine das ist schnell
gemacht aber ich warte einfach auf die
ergebnisse berichten